these are some of the storage units
where Russia houses its Atomic Warheads
satellite images are a key tool for the
world to keep an eye on the nuclear
sites dotted across the country
as Russian President Vladimir Putin
suffers losses in Ukraine he has
suggested that he was ready to use his
nuclear Arsenal um
a nuclear strike is still widely seen as
an unlikely scenario but Western
officials have said they are concerned
and President Biden warned the world
could face the prospect of an Armageddon
so how would a Russian nuclear strike
play out it's not like there is a big
red button on the president's desk by
looking at a map of Russia we can learn
a lot about how Putin would activate his
Atomic Force
these dots represent the known locations
where Russia houses some of its nuclear
weapons
faces like these have been identified by
analysts who monitor nuclear arsenals
using satellite images and other sources
the red ones indicate sites where
tactical nuclear warheads are stored
typically these are lower yield weapons
used on Delivery Systems with a range
under 310 miles and the blue dots
represent where some of moscow's
strategic weapons are deployed these
have more power and can travel up to
about 9000 miles
if Moscow decided to launch a nuclear
attack many Western and Ukrainian
officials believe it would turn to
tactical weapons
normally it is assumed that strategic
weapons are the last things you touch
Hans Christensen is the director of the
nuclear information project and has been
studying Russian nuclear weapons for
decades the assumption is the tactical
nuclear weapons to the extent that they
would escalate to nuclear use would be
the first that would be used Russia has
2889 Warheads in storage according to
American analysts that's almost a
thousand more than the US
and even those tactical weapons can be
very powerful and destructive the rn40
gravity bomb carried in Jets such as
these has the same estimated power as 30
kilotons of dynamite that's more than
the bombs that were dropped on Hiroshima
and Nagasaki at about 15 to 20 kilotons
and much less than Russia's strategic
weapons these intercontinental ballistic
missiles for example can have a yield of
300 to 800 kilotons a strike using those
weapons would be enough to destroy any
major city according to Christensen
if Russia was to actually deploy
tactical nuclear weapons at these sites
it would first have to tackle some
logistical challenges
that starts with retrieving the WarHeads
from the storage bunkers or units that
they're housed in those weapons are all
in storage facilities Pavel podwig is a
geneva-based nuclear weapons expert who
tracks Russian storage bases these are
normally some distance from The Delivery
Systems take this site in bilgore near
the border with Ukraine for example on a
nuclear order the site Personnel would
have to retrieve the WarHeads from
bunkers then they would load them onto
trucks in special climate-controlled
containers and transport them to an
Airfield or designated point near a
missile base like this one
once they arrive they would then need to
be installed on a launcher or airplane
so actually deploying them for combat
could take many hours or up to a few
days military analysts say that whole
process would be very hard to complete
without other countries realizing as
movements are being tracked by
intelligence teams according to defense
experts so Russia appears to have taken
steps to be less visible if you look at
the satellite photos over these nuclear
weapon storage sites they typically have
sort of a a roof or garage at the
entrance so any truck that drives up
goes into this garage so you can't see
what they're loading on board but
increasing the chances the message of a
strike would spread is the multiple
Personnel involved along the way
the group responsible for Russia's
nuclear weapons is a special unit called
the 12th Chief directorate analysts say
the individuals in that Force could
potentially oppose strikes the military
would be part of that process they would
have a chance at least to offer their
opinion on that plan and whether it
should go ahead if movement at the
facilities was detected the West could
respond in a number of ways according to
military analysts one scenario is that
countries could Target moscow's storage
bases which carries huge risks while
another is imposing more sanctions
strategic nuclear weapons like this
intercontinental ballistic missile are
even less likely to be used but
hypothetically they would be much
quicker to deploy they're standing in
their silos the missiles or their
onboard ballistic missile submarines and
they're loaded with nuclear warheads um
they're ready to fly on you know in a
few minutes
[Music]
however before any of that Putin would
need to actually order a stripe and
there's a series of steps that need to
take place within the Kremlin for that
to happen the process is secretive and
hard to Monitor and could even have
changed since the Ukraine War Began
defense analysts have made an educated
guess how it would unfold based on
documents and sources the theory is that
um
that there are three people that need to
be involved
um in an actual launch of Russian
nuclear weapons the Russian President
Putin and the minister of defense and
then also the Chief of the Armed Forces
they're supposed to have three
briefcases so to speak electronic uh
communication devices they can use to
activate the nuclear option
some defense experts believe that two
out of three of those officials would
need to agree for the strike to be
carried out if that is the in fact the
setup
then it's very different from the
American setup where the precedent has
the sole authority to launch this and it
doesn't require
he doesn't need approval from anyone
else
in addition to the chain of command
Russia has a strategic planning document
or military Doctrine which lays out how
nuclear weapons could be used
the document says it allows the use of
nuclear weapons if they or other types
of weapons of mass destruction are used
against it as well as in the event of
aggression that threatens the existence
of the Russian Federation the
interpretation of that document rests on
the shoulders of Putin who has already
said the territorial Integrity of Russia
may be threatened and has claimed the
annexation of four Ukrainian territories
when asked if Russia could use nuclear
weapons in Ukraine Kremlin spokesman
Dmitry peskov told the Wall Street
Journal we consider such inflated
nuclear rhetoric unacceptable
but with Moscow facing setbacks in
Ukraine officials and Military analysts
say the use of tactical weapons can't be
completely rolled out